I was someone who worked in the White
House I worked for the President of the
United States I had an up-and-coming
career in politics
but when Ryan Hampton suffered an injury
prescription painkillers led him to
heroin
his addiction story he says is typical
of the opioid crisis driven by the drug
companies this crisis has ballooned all
over in all 50 states and these drug
makers are 100% accountable you know
they need to pay for the the damage that
they have done to our communities
Johnson and Johnson will pay for what a
judge called false misleading and
dangerous marketing of painkillers
Johnson & Johnson motivated by greed and
avarice is responsible for the opioid
epidemic in our state Johnson & Johnson
will finally be held accountable for
thousands of deaths and addiction caused
by their activities it's come too late
for the families of some I feel like my
boy is looking down but I think my son
and Austin Johnson or Johnson says it
warned doctors of the risks highlighting
the crisis of over prescribing in
America we have sympathy for all who
suffer from substance abuse but Johnson
and Johnson did not cause the opioid
abuse crisis here in Oklahoma or
anywhere in this country Johnson &
Johnson isn't the first drug company to
suffer in the courts last year a Mara
Salzburg incorporation was fined six
hundred and twenty five million dollars
over the sale of syringes containing
cancer drugs that were prepared in an
unsterile environment
earlier this year Monsanto was ordered
to pay two billion dollars to a couple
after the weed killer it produces was
linked to their cancer diagnosis and
GlaxoSmithKline played a record three
billion dollars in 2012 for the
misbranding and failure to report safety
data of antidepressants
it remains the largest payment ever by a
drug company in the u.s. experts say
this is gonna take 20 to 30 years to
clean up the mess Ryan now works to help
others get clean and hundreds more
lawsuits are pending in a country with
five percent of the world's population
but which uses 95% of its opioids it is
a uniquely American epidemic Gregg Milam
Sky News Los Angeles